at the busiest port complex in the
united states this is the global supply
chain crisis in action a backlog of
container ships waiting to dock those
that have they can't unload fast enough
the queue at times 70 ships long
stretches miles out into the pacific and
the demand for what they're carrying
grows
this is what a post pandemic surge does
an online buying boom putting pressure
on logistics the solution one backed by
joe biden this week is to begin 24 7
operations
everybody agrees we're in a crisis so
that's number one
everybody agrees we need a solution
so the question is what are those
short-term solutions what are the
long-term solutions what's important is
we cannot be in this situation
next time there's an unforeseeable event
america's truckers are the next link in
that chain the delays cost and for
drivers like renee frustration grows
sometimes on drivers they get mad you
know i understand that i am one of those
you know but we try to do our job the
best you know but we're wasting too much
time inside of that you know it's like
five six hours you know just waiting for
one love
and just like in the uk for everyone
else the concern is shortages
the calls to lisa's toy shop haven't
stopped
tooth for will have to leave an iou
all this uncertainty with christmas
approaching
ordering ordering ordering and ordering
early and ordering deep because you
don't know
if some items aren't going to come in so
you order heavy on just everything and
hope something comes in
i think for some business it's harder i
spoke with a hardware store and they're
only getting uh 40 of their stuff in so
and this is early christmas yeah
for shoppers getting what you can when
you can
seems to have become the norm
the big retailers here are even
considering chartering their own smaller
cargo ships which could then dock at
smaller ports but to guarantee that
supply would cost more and we all know
who'd end up paying that
like everything in the world of shipping
it takes time to turn things around even
with some added presidential urgency
they say it will be next summer before
things are back to normal here greg
milam sky news long beach california